Does the following table
represent a linear equation?
So let's see what's
going on here.
When x is negative 7, y is 4.
Then when x is
negative 3, y is 3.
So let's see what happened
to what our change in x was.
So our change in
x-- and I could even
write it over here,
our change in x.
So going from negative
7 to negative 3,
we had an increase in 4 in x.
And what was our change in y?
And this triangle, that's
just the Greek letter delta.
It's shorthand for "change in."
Well, our change in y
when x increased by 4,
our y-value went from 4 to 3.
So our change in
y is negative 1.
Now, in order for this
to be a linear equation,
the ratio between our change
in y and our change in x
has to be constant.
So our change in
y over change in x
for any two points
in this equation
or any two points in the table
has to be the same constant.
When x changed by 4, y
changed by negative 1.
Or when y changed by
negative 1, x changed by 4.
So we have to have a
constant change in y
with respect to x
of negative 1/4.
Let's see if this is true.
So the next two points, when
I go from negative 3 to 1,
once again I'm
increasing x by 4.
And once again, I'm
decreasing y by negative 1.
So we have that same ratio.
Now, let's look at
this last point.
When we go from 1 to
7 in the x-direction,
we are increasing by 6.
And when we go from 2 to 1,
we are still decreasing by 1.
So now this ratio, going
from this third point
to this fourth point,
is negative 1/6.
So it is not.
So just for this last
point right over here,
for this last point, our change
in y over change in x, or I
should say, really, between
these last two points
right over here, our change
in y over change in x--
let me clear this up.
Let me make it clear.
So just between these
last-- in magenta.
Just between these last
two points over here,
our change in y is negative
1, and our change in x is 6.
So we have a different rate of
change of y with respect to x.
Because we had a different
rate of change of y
with respect to x, or ratio
between our change in y
and change in x, this is
not a linear equation.
No, not a linear equation.